[Music]
hello Thank You sander for the
introduction and thank you all for
coming to my talk I'm Robert I am a data
scientist at go data driven and this is
my first ever conference talk so please
send me some of that first-timers lovin
so who here is familiar with Reddit yeah
all rights most people in the room
that's good that's good
great so most of the most of you have
probably run into posts like this one so
you see some texts a story like Research
Institute blah blah mouth surgery blah
blah felt a little high leaks in the iso
flooring chambers blah blah blah lab
manager chewed out the postdoc blah blah
blah and then at the very bottom you see
TL DR recreational drug usage taught me
to recognize anesthesia links leaks so
for those of you who are not really
well-versed in internet speak TL DR
stands for too long didn't read now that
is we have a long possibly rambling
story and then it's capped off with TL
DR and then a pissy recap of what the
person just wrote so this is an example
of what's called an abstracted
summarization which is a type of summary
created by first digesting a long piece
of text and then generating a new
original shorter version of that text
now this is a task that for most humans
comes quite easily I think I wrote my
first book report when I was about nine
but it's an open research problem in the
machine learning community now if you
spend a few more hours at work on reddit
you're more like you're likely to come
across something like this which is post
by user Auto TL DR almost always in
response to the posting of a news
article with a cohesive summary of the
article and the admission that the
author is in fact a bot that's right so
user Auto TL DR is a computer program
and is able to generate coherent text
summaries despite what I just said about
summarization being an open research
problem so you might ask yourself how is
it possible and it turns out that
there's another approach for generating
summer
is called extractive summarization and
the idea here is that instead of
generating your own original summary you
just want to find a few sentences in the
original text which when concatenated
together convey the main ideas of the
original text and now that might sound
like a silly idea and you may not expect
that to even work but recall that what
we were doing back in our high school
days when we were preparing for exams we
were reading our textbooks we were
highlighting key sentences as we were
going long and then the night before the
exam when we were cramming we would just
reread only those sentences in order to
refresh our memories about what the book
was about now from a programming
perspective this technique has a lot of
advantages because this technique
doesn't require the generation of
original texts which require a deep
model of all the things which make
language difficult like syntax and
grammar and style the summaries are
extractive algorithm outputs will
automatically read like they were penned
by human author because they were or at
least the individual sentences within
the summary will sound like they're
written by a human additionally for
certain information dense media and in
particular for news articles this
approach has a decent shot at working
because these media by nature don't
smear concepts like character motivation
or personality across multiple
paragraphs which require model
abstraction which is also incredibly
difficult so now it turns out that in
contrast to this state of research and
abstract of summarization we're at a
point where we can write software that
can generate extract of summaries
automatically and have been doing so for
roughly 15 years one particularly
effective algorithm for generating
extractive summarizations which is the
technology behind simile which is in
turn powers auto TL DR is text ranked
and that's what I'd like to discuss with
you today
so to begin I'd like to start with the
takeaways from my talk one texts rank is
an algorithm that can be used to make
extractive summaries of text and is
natural language agnostic which means
that it doesn't really care what the
input language is although
implementations of this algorithm
certainly are
Jennsen is my recommended Python
implementation of texturing for English
text and Jensen can be modified to work
for a number of other languages and I'll
talk about which ones towards the end of
my talk
got it okay good
so now for the details here we see text
Frank bring the order into text it was
written by Rada Chia and Paul taro in
2004 and was a product of its time
because just six years earlier Sergey
Brin and Larry Page had released their
paper the page rank citation ranking
bringing order to the web outlining page
rank the algorithm that formed the basis
for Google's original search engine
which in 2004 had already established
Google's preeminence over the venn
darlings of the search world like Lycos
and Alta Vista and I'm probably dating
myself by even acknowledging I've
knowledge of Lycos let alone had ever
used it now Brendon pages insight was
that if you were to view the world wide
web as a mathematical graph with no true
jumping representing websites and edges
representing websites pointing to one
another via hyperlinks the structure of
that graph contains all the information
necessary to determine the relative
importance of each website that is to
say the importance of a website could be
indicated in some relative way based on
its relationship with other websites and
not per se in some absolute way based on
texts and tags forming the content of
that website and now as a side and I'm
really gonna date myself when I say this
back in the early search days web sites
used to game content based search
systems by writing popular query terms
and the backgrounds of the website so
the background the website would be
yellow and you'd write things like Yahoo
Yahoo Yahoo Yahoo a thousand times in
yellow over that background so I had a
side job at Google where I had to check
of a website but literally pointing my
website my browser it's the suspected
websites and in press ctrl-a and see if
anything suddenly popped out and the
highlighted text but anyway so this
relative importance could then be used
to rank its
to a search query so if you had two
websites with the same search signals
the one with the greater importance
would be ranked higher and it's we all
know how that worked out for google so
how does PageRank work well first you
make a graph node for every webpage
publicly accessible via the World Wide
Web
- if one website links to another you
draw a little directed edge between the
respective nodes and three for each node
slash webpage you calculate an
importance weight based on the graph
data and so the question becomes how do
you calculate that importance weight so
the essential basic idea is that the
more websites that link to your website
the more important your particular
website was so for instance in this
illustration where the size of the node
represents its importance the green
nodes are all of lesser importance
because no other website points to them
with the exception of that guy on the
left side but we're not gonna worry
about the little guy and the yellow note
here is very important because lots of
different websites point to it now
except if that were it this would be a
really fragile system for instance
setting up a thousand cheap websites to
do nothing else except link to your
personal web page it would be a way to
game the system so what Brandon page did
instead to account for this was to also
account for the back linked websites all
own importance is to wait that edge
account so particular that's why the red
node there at the top is so large
there's only one link going to it but
that link is coming from a really
important website therefore also making
that red node important by association
some more prostrate specifically every
websites important was evenly spread
across its edges so that if you were
website and you had three outgoing links
and you had an importance of three you
would contribute one unit of importance
to each of those linked websites now
you've been following me so far you've
probably noticed that this importance
calculation is recursive you need to
know what
sites importances in order to calculate
their importances which sounds like a
case of the dragon eating its own tail
but one can show that there's a
straightforward iterative process for
solving for the importances which I'll
illustrate with a toy example so here we
have a toy internets where we have four
web sites web site a points to the other
three web sites B and D both points to
other web sites and web sites D points
back to a now you start with this graph
and you take their weighted edge sorry
there are directed edges and then you
create a system of linear equations from
them so here these unknown variables are
simply the unknown importances for each
of the web sites and these fractions
represent basically how many outgoing
links each of these web sites had and
where they went to we take our linear
equations we make a matrix formula out
of them or this matrix here is this
adjacency matrix I was talking about and
then if we rewrite it like this it
becomes clear that we have an eigenvalue
problem that is to say we're looking for
a vector which we multiply it against
that matrix is itself now the math tells
us that if we start simply with a vector
of ones multiply that against our jccc
matrix take the result of that multiply
it again against the jason c matrix may
keep doing that over and over and over
again eventually the resulting vector
will stabilize to some values and when
it does then we'll have our vector of
importance weights for all the websites
sergey brin called sorry Brin and page
called this the PageRank and now the
solving process comes from dynamical
Systems Theory but it also lends itself
to a nice probabilistic interpretation
that is to say that the node importance
is also the probability that a random
internet server will end up on your
website and perhaps the way you can see
that is with that initial vector of ones
we're sort of putting equal drops of
probability at every website and then it
just flows through the network of our
graph over and over again until it's
sort of reached a sort of state of
equilibrium
now this interpretation comes in handy
when you're directed graph is such that
there are nodes from which a surfer
can't escape because they have no going
links or that there are correct
connected components such that you can't
reach the
from the other so say you have one note
it has two outgoing links and then from
those links you sort of end up in little
loops in this situation the solving
technique will give ambiguous results
so what Brennan page did was they
introduced the chance that the surfer
instead of moving from one website to
another via a link would simply skip to
another link and intuitively maybe that
makes sense to you as well because if
you've just got stuck in a circle of
three links at some point you get bored
of following links and just try
something new at random so if you take
that into account then your final
equation starts to look like this where
we still have our adjacency matrix and
we have this new company it's the matrix
B and we've introduced a damping factor
D which is the probability that the
surfer will random skip to some other
website through their experiments page
and print determined that a decent value
of D was 0.15 so 15% and now our
iterative and a solving process now
works with all sorts of network
topologies and that's it well you're not
in this room to hear about PageRank
you're here in this room to hear about
text rank so what precisely is the
connection between the two
now malkia and taro remember these are
the authors of the text rank paper
realize that a piece of text could also
be seen as a graph to which one could
also apply the PageRank algorithm so how
do we represent our text as a graph
first instead of the nodes of our graph
representing websites they now represent
individual sentences secondly instead of
the edges of our graph representing
hyperlinks pointing from one website to
another
we now have sentences referring to one
another in some way which will become
clear later in the talk but whereas a
website has a definite set of other
websites which that links the said can't
immediately said about sentences and as
a result whereas once we had a sparse
graph we now have a dense graph that is
to say all the nodes connect to each
other however here we have to treat the
edges differently than we did in the
PageRank case why well whereas a website
is selective in the websites in which to
choose to link to a bear therefore the
first approximation all the outgoing
edges can be equally weighted the same
doesn't hold for a Centon
slinking all of those instances to it in
a text surely some connections are more
relevant or important than others and
certainly some connections are
completely non-existent which means we
need some way of weighting our text
graph edges the approach taken by text
rank is to first apply some measure of
similarity between the sentences and
then to use that as the edge weight
thus the tanks rank algorithm consists
of 1 make a graph node for every
sentence in the text to draw an edge
between every pair of nodes 3 calculate
weights for each edge using our
similarity measure for calculating for
each node sentence and importance weight
by the PageRank technique now notice in
this algorithm that this algorithm is
natural language agnostic which means
that no part place that I actually
specify any technique which is dependent
on the characteristics of a particular
language such as English where a choice
of language comes into place when you
actually try and implement this
algorithm and that'll be the focus in
the next section of my talk and that's
it for text rank to create an extractive
summarization tool using it you add two
additional steps first you have to
actually parse your text into sentences
and that's more difficult than it looks
and lastly when you're done you simply
order your sentences and decreasing
importance concatenate them until you
reach some sort of pre specified word
limit precisely this is done by the
Python module I want to tell you about
next which is Jenson so who here's use
Jenson before great so those of you
who've used ism Jenson poly you
discovered it because at some point you
were looking into topic modeling and you
discovered the Jenson is this really
nice distributed Lda implementation the
second most possible reason probably
reason that you were investigating
Jenson is because it also has a nice set
of word vectors available but what you
might have overlooked in Jensen's API is
its text summarization feature here text
is simply the string we'd like to
summarize a ratio and word count or the
ways we set the
if I'd worn limit on our eventual
summary and split provides this option
for outputting your rank sentences as a
list as opposed to some sort of
concatenated string which can come in
handy if you need to use each of these
individual sentences in a right order
for some future downstream purpose or if
you don't like separating your sentences
with the single space now summarizes the
implementation of an algorithm and so
the first question one might ask
of summarize is what choice of sentence
- molarity the Jensen make if we were to
look back at the original paper the
authors suggested this following which
is a bunch of math so I'll just tell you
what it means in English first you take
your two sentences you try and find
words which appear in both of those
sentences you count how many of those
words there are and then you normalize
that count in some way by the total
length of the two sentences the
similarity measure has a few properties
we like for one the greater the overlap
in words between the two sentences the
greater the similarity secondly if the
overlap actually represents a small
percentage of all the words in the two
sentences the similarity is penalized
and lastly it can be zero if two
sentences have no words in common thus
reducing the size of our graph and thus
the computational complexity of the
sentence importance calculation however
Jensen made a number of design decisions
to improve upon this measure so recall
that the goal of here is to be able to
develop some sense for whether two
sentences refer to one another or put
the other way around
- better discern whether two sentences
are completely not referring to one
another so towards that second goal one
thing we could do is before doing any of
the math first strip out all the words
that dilute our ability to distinguish
between two sentences in particular we
can remove stop words or extremely
common words that don't do much to
distinguish the informational content of
a piece of text here we see the actual
stop words used or hard-coded into
Jensen and for those of you unfamiliar
with frozen sets they're simply
immutable sets which are useful for
making set subsets stripping stop words
also has the additional benefit of
setting the similarity of two sentences
to zero that don't share any concepts
but perhaps both include the word
now to be fair to the authors they of
the original text writing paper they did
suggest that instead of looking at all
words in the sentences you simply look
only at the nouns and the verbs and this
to a fair extent is similar to stop word
removal however this approach would
still give equal weight to all remaining
words and we can easily imagine
situations where some words might be
more importance towards our goal of
distinguishing two sentences than others
which leads us to Jen some improvement
number two which is to do away with the
originally proposed binary word
indicators and instead work weight the
presence of a word in the context of a
sentence that appears in and also in the
context of all words appearing in all
sentences in the text so specifically
what I mean as a first step we can
weight the words that appear multiple
times in a sense it's more heavily and
second we can penalize words that while
not stop words nevertheless occur
frequently in our text and these types
of words tend to arise due to being the
main specific words such as money in a
text about banking or player in the
context of a corpus of football texts so
more specifically each word each
sentence received what is called a
tf-idf score so term frequency inverse
document frequency score which is the
product of a the number of times the
word appears in a sentence and one over
the frequency with which it appears in
any one sentence that is its inverse
document frequency so our similarity
score then becomes the following again
math but I'll just say it in English
again I'll look for all the words which
appear in both sentences and then take
the product of the tf-idf scores of
those words and then sum up those
products again by normalizing by some
factor as a side note what Jensen
actually does is calculating not the
tf-idf score but something called the B
m25 score of each word which is almost
the same except that it modifies the
term frequency calculation a bit so that
it saturates such that the more it
appears the less of an influence that
has in the overall score
and that saturation point varies
depending on how length your sentences
in regards to the average length of the
sentences near text so if your sentence
is shorter than average
that TF score can saturate more quickly
now by switching over the tf-idf scores
instead of using a binary indicators
we've now introduced a way to not only
measure the overlap between two
sentences but also how relevant that
overlap is in the context of all
sentences in the original text however
this approach has one major deficiency
namely that this measure only increases
when the exact same word appears in both
sentences this can leave the situations
where two sentences both have to do with
the same concept in this case the
concept of running but because one is
she runs and the other was they were
running their similarity according to
our measure is precisely zero so what we
would like is some representation of
both sentences where the verb appears in
some common form say run and we can
imagine lots of situations like this for
instance fishing fish and Fisher could
all be represented by fish consistent
consistency and consistently by consists
and argues arguing and argued by argu
note that we don't actually require that
that representation be an actual English
word and our there are a few approaches
to addressing this problem for instance
we could have some complicated lookup
function which replaces was were and is
with be the verb of existence but these
are relatively computationally expensive
it turns out that one can actually get
quite far by simply taking your word and
then chopping off the end of it in some
intelligent way this process is called
stemming and it is Jennison improvement
number three so what does that look like
here we see a sentence and this result
after having been passed through Jensen
stemmer note that is far from perfect
for a particular quite has been reduced
to the unrelated quit but because
stemming algorithms are all rule-based
and quick to execute it makes a nice
balance between increasing the chance of
recognizing a matching concepts between
two sentences while not incurring too
great a computational cost and that's
Jensen's approach to sentence similarity
to recap first remove all stop words
from all sentences and focus on words
that better distinguish between two
sentences
to stem the remaining words to increase
the similarity between two sentences
with words differing only in inflection
but being the same in concept and lastly
calculate similarities for all sentence
pairs using token tf-idf scores or
really B m25 scores and there is one
other non-text rate rank related trick
that Jenson has a butt sleeve turns out
that breaking text up into its component
sentences is a non-trivial task
something I alluded to earlier and a
particular the dot symbol or the period
because it can take on so many different
meanings in English can fool and
automated splitting algorithm so Jenson
approaches this by using a pair of reg X
is to ignore most abbreviations of
titles like mr. and mrs. and also for
ignoring algorithm sorry acronyms like
NASA and that's it for Jensen's
implementation of text rank now my
opinion Jensen does a great job
summarizing short text and in particular
news articles but should come as no
surprise and only does really well with
English texts after all the stop word
list contains one of those entries the
stemming algorithm used was designed
specifically for the English language
and the regex is it uses to deal with
the dot symbol is optimised for English
grammar but because you and I know
understand now so well why Jensen is
successful with the english-language
text and because Jensen is an open
source project we can open up the hood
rip out all the english pacific bits and
replace them with their equivalents in
our favorite non english language so
let's start with the easy bit first we
need to stop words list so we visit our
friends over at stop words either it's o
find the repository corresponding to our
non-english language and borrowed their
list being sure to give them appropriate
credit I count 57 different languages
and in addition to all of our Western
European friends there are also a stop
word list for languages such as
Indonesian and Afrikaans and Kurdish and
Bengali etc etc this is the repo for the
Dutch language at the bottom you see
stop words list in both JSON and text
format all you have to do is bundle them
up and then drop them into Jensen's
parsing pre-processing file so you just
trip out that frozen set with the one
from stop words ISO next up we have to
pick a stammer there are a large number
of them in NLT K's stem package amongst
which is a particularly fast set called
snowball stammers you'll find summers
for Arabic Danish Dutch English Finnish
French German Hungarian which I think
I'm supposed to call magyar Italian
Norwegian Portuguese Romanian Russian
Spanish and Swedish using one is simply
a matter of including ltk in your
environment and replacing Jensen's
porter stemmer class with your choice of
stammer in this case I've chosen to use
NLT K's Dutch language snowball stammer
and I mentioned a number from LT K there
are a number of European languages
missing from that list mostly from the
Slavic family of languages if you just
google around you'll find results for
summers in these languages so it's not
really impossible the thing is that they
typically are in Java so you have to
translate that logic yourself to Python
suddenly further afield you have like
Turkish which has a suffix only
agglutinative language lends itself well
to stemming indeed one finds Turkish
numbers quite easily on the internet I
think also in Python but in general just
because it's not supported in a major
Python project doesn't mean that doesn't
exist or it's not possible it just means
it requires my work either translating
Java to Python code or poking around the
websites of NLP research groups at a
university in the country whose language
you'd like to summarize note that
although NL TK has a large number of
stem errs and particularly non-european
ones there are a few notable exceptions
first and foremost because it isn't a
character-based language Chinese text
summarization does not seem to be
possible by our BM 25 base sentence
similarity measure less obvious choice
would be Hebrew and that's in part
because it's written form typically
doesn't include vowels but I hope
there's enough here to make most view in
the room happy lastly in principle we
should also swap out the those
abbreviation regex as I mentioned and
additionally add new ones on a
case-by-case basis specific to the
language you'd like to summarize I
haven't been able to find one library
which provides these things so you're
probably just going to require the
services of somebody with a domain
knowledge of that language so that's all
well and good in principle but I
actually went ahead and did this one for
Dutch on an afternoon project I call it
saman falter which is the 2007 play on
words for the Dutch word for
summarization and you can view what I
did at my github again I want to
emphasize said the lion's share of the
work was done by the lovely people at
Jensen all I did was simply glue all the
pieces together now as this is a data
conference I would normally want to show
you some examples of what I did but
given the medium of a presentation and
that not everyone in the room
necessarily speaks Dutch skip that but
if you're interested you can simply
clone my clone my repo and then try it
out on the morning newspaper tomorrow
morning and that's my talk to conclude
I'd like to throw the takeaways back up
on the screen once more so text rank is
an algorithm based on page rank and it
can be used to make extractive summaries
of texts that is natural language
agnostic
although the implementations of this
algorithm are not number two Jensen is
my preferred Python implementation of
text rank for the English language and
three Jensen can be modified to work for
a number of other languages
check out my saman falter for an example
in Dutch thanks for your attention and
I'd be happy to field some questions
thank you very much for your talk we
have five minutes of questions
afterwards we have a little bit of a
longer break for people sort of want to
have or we have a little bit of a longer
break for the people that stay in this
room then five minutes for everyone at
once you go to the other room we have a
break of five minutes this is because of
the lunch queue so we want to minimize
that so five minutes for questions for
everyone who sticks around in this room
we can do a little bit longer thank you
so as I understood correctly that
similarity measure between sentences is
fully symmetric between sentences right
so there's no notion of order so it's
the symmetric matrix that you're getting
the eigenvector from in the end and or
but that's so it's not really referral
that you're measuring as such because
the sentence rarely refers to one
further down in the text I guess so no
question right so you're right that the
it's sort of a stretch to find out what
exactly the relationship is between
sentences in the text rank environment
as opposed to websites in the PageRank
environments it's not actually
specifically stated somewhere in that
original paper they just said hey we can
use this algorithm if we do this to make
a graph out of it
so I think you have to play a little
fast and loose with this idea of
relationship in sentences it's just like
there's this latent concept of one
sentence referring to another based on
information they're trying to convey on
a very abstract level no and then trying
to make that in some way concrete you
then resort to looking at the words in
those sentences all right so I'm gonna
count hands again I see one two three
four in the back and five I'm gonna do
left to right makes it easier to walk
thank you for the amazing talk I have a
question so when it comes to the
similarity matrix used between sentences
you mentioned that Jainism is using by
default tf-idf would solve some of the
issues as you mentioned
using your example that you said saran
source is running this is solved by
stemming but what have you had the
sentence seiran's into the building and
then here asked into something else in a
building so tf-idf would fail there
right but what if you could use the dog
to vac or some other representation that
captures meaning rather than
co-occurrence of course have you tried
that so a couple things at play here one
I was looking for a fast tool because I
was trying to see if I can put this in
the system that just digests pieces of
text really rapidly so incorporating
some larger model would really slow
things down for instance you could even
do something before even resorted to
deep learning models you can use the
monetization algorithms but even that I
felt like was too great a computational
cost for the performance that we get out
and then the last concern is that even
if you were to use word Tyvek or to vex
but focus on individual words but then
the context of those words is also
important and so you have maybe want to
convert your word into a sentence
somehow and I started your word vector
into a sentence vector somehow and
that's also kind of an open problem Oh
dr. Beck oh so I haven't used
specifically dr. Beck okay so we got to
number two Thanks I also wanted to ask
her the doctor vector yeah but I asked
so another question is I found something
missing in the optimization like you
there are fixed phrases like United
States and if you separated the two
words there are totally different no
meaning that's correct
and like I said this is like an
algorithm which plays off for
computational cost or like little
accents like this so if you're right if
if you just if one sentence says United
States and the other sentence says
America you're not going to get a match
but hopefully there will be enough
information surrounding those words and
if not yeah it's not going to for that
pair of sentences it's not going to work
but maybe those sentences won't be the
most likely candidates for some
extractive summarization algorithm
anyway we'll go to question number three
so that's you
dr. vex Oh anyone else for dr. Vik
because okay if you could pass this on
hello thanks for the talk you'll compare
PageRank with text rank and you said
page rank is sparse connecting sparsely
connected graph and there is like a
random surfer motto that some surfer
will just randomly drum 15% of time or
jumps to some random notes that knot can
connect it and with text rank you said
this densely connected graph does it
means fully connected so all knows any
pair of nodes are connected to each
other
thanks yes so you start out with a fully
connected graph yeah once you calculate
these edge weights hopefully a number of
these edge weights will be zero so you
can view those as being removed from the
graph okay
so that's I think but there's also that
additional coma where we had that random
jumping that random surfing component is
also incorporated into the page sorry
it's a text rank algorithm also there's
also like a certain percentage that note
we'll just do and so your interpretation
of this jump like that two sentences
don't actually share any words in common
but talk about the same concepts by
chance maybe you could view it that way
but like I mentioned it one of the
previous questions you have to play a
little fast and loose with the analogy
okay so then we'll quickly go to the
last question I'm sorry I can't
incorporate you I don't know if I'd
missed you or did you just raise your
hand
okay sorry so if we're out of time we
can also talk about from that point so
my question is about very last step so I
see how you rank the sentences on the
importance and relevance but that you
ever find that when you're picking the
law sentences for a summary that the
sentence is the varying big were too
similar to each other for example yeven
document and they're talking about three
different reasons why something is the
case and a human will pick those three
different visions I suppose well if you
use the algorithm and just pick the most
relevant sentences a month might kinda
be too similar to each other the sender
sense does it make sense okay but
because you can set your word limit you
can if you start experiencing that you
can also just reduce the word count of
the eventual summary and hopefully that
will decrease the chance that's two
sentences at the very end or quite so
much one another at least have
similarity scores like one another would
not appear both in a summary okay think
okay again apologies I didn't see you
there because of time issues we have to
conclude here thank you very much for
your presentation please give him a warm
applause
[Applause]